it's time to live from the Jon Lovitz
Agastya this
[Applause]
Kevin Smith
[Music]
it is New Year's Eve in Hollywood so
let's babble the [ __ ] ah let's do that I
am the big fat New Year's baby Kevin
Smith and I'm the drunk man from old
last year Ralph Garman welcome one
welcome all to New Year's babble Eve
we're gonna wring out this rotten
[ __ ] year and bring in the next
wretched year no this was a good year
yeah because it's the last year because
you know what happens to 2012 the Mayans
returned from space riding an asteroid
and [ __ ] there's two of them they're
gonna hit the earth at the same time or
get released on the same day if I
remember correctly and then Ben Affleck
puts animal crackers and now John
Arwen's plows and we're [ __ ]
John Cusack gets in a car and has to
drive over broken bridges and [ __ ]
that's true if you could this is the
year to get friendly with John Cusack
based on that movie yeah
[ __ ] can navigate the apocalypse
thanks so much for coming out everybody
and spending New Year's Eve with us what
a great crowd we're happy to be here a
great patch it's a bittersweet evening
for me it is great to be here but as as
Mike who made this for me reminds me
there is a Batman Marathon going on at
the hub right now
he made this little medallion for me
happy new year old chums and it says
Batman on it and it's it's it's lovely
it's the actual logo from the TV show
you don't see that very often aren't you
married a [ __ ] guy move on I'm just
saying right now Adam West is Christ
next I'm gonna blow them for everybody
right here is the best thing that ever
happened to me Rock thing right now Adam
West is probably saying mr. freeze but
poor deluded genius yeah but you just
did it so we're all good quickly old
chump pop my champagne cork anal Batman
meet the Pfister that's the that's the
villain in that episode it's a dark dark
episode Batcave takes on a whole new
meaning a Woody Allen all of a sudden
Batcave takes on a whole new meaning
[ __ ] right out of his pixie boots I'm
sorry dude isn't it turning 2012 making
like nineteen sixties references Adam
West [ __ ] Woody Allen that's gonna be
one of those shows Kevin Smith for those
of you who are playing along with the
Hollywood babble-on drinking game this
evening I thought we'd go over the rules
real quick there are several rules that
are sort of constants have been there
since the beginning we added a bunch of
new rules that were submitted over the
past year to the game this year as well
some of the old ones from last year like
number five if Kevin deem is one of
Ralph's impressions unacceptable you
take two drinks so people would have to
take two drinks right then when you
mocked my impressions I didn't I've been
demon except oh dude you have anything
from this decade yeah yeah
also on the list if Ralph says how dare
you sir you take a drink that'll happen
that I if Kevin says and what not you
take a drink you [ __ ] gonna be drunk
man you watch what not free evening
mm-hmm but not which is much sex a
balloon not yeah
Peter Kevin Oh Ralph says give the penis
to sandwich you finish your drink I know
that was like our original catchphrase
it's gone by the wayside it was and we
replaced it with other things you
started talking about Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
yes we did if Kevin imitates sucking a
[ __ ] by going down on the microphone you
take a drink like what are the chances
that's some of the new rules if Ralph
forgets to cue the theme song for one of
the recurring segments you take a drink
it's very possible that will happen
tonight
if Kevin spontaneously bursts into song
you take two drinks that might happen if
ralph sings Edelweiss you drink until he
stops how dare you sir her roses you
drink until he stops that's a long cuz
you go for a while like 800 iyslah just
do the one just do a device watch Hey oh
my god I'm out of air that's [ __ ]
crazy that's the one word and then it
goes on another ten minutes you'll be
piss drunk
if Kevin shouts diplomatic immunity can
you take the drink
[Music]
if the McDonald's fry girl recommends a
shamrock shake with that you take two
drinks
if Kevin defends the town list [ __ ]
Chelsea Handler you take a drag she's a
nice girl I'm neutral
if the crowd beats Kevin to a pulp take
a drink
yeah really became boo Year's Eve really
quickly and lastly if ralph gives Kevin
the spooky clown you're finish your
drink maybe later we can work that in
giving me the spooky clown sounds so
erotic we charge like a dude I'm so
drunk
Ralph's giving me the spooky spooky
clowning you have courtesy of a
reach-around or reach a clown it's blue
confetti all over all right it's time
for the shoutouts one of our favorite
parts the show where we get to thank
people who came particularly long
distances or here for celebrating a
special occasion like us we're all here
so we're taking special occasion right
tonight really there's so many that got
sent in tonight like this we just can't
get to all of them so we want to
apologize if we don't get to yours we're
getting to as many as we can
I'm even bumping email to next week so
we can get as many as we can in all
right but first and foremost Celeste you
take a drink we need we need a theme
song
[Music]
so get your [ __ ] out
[Music]
last one of the new year ya have to get
it out of my system I had 2012 no more
no really it's my one terrible [ __ ]
weakness I have to blow microphone yeah
check out this one comes from Lloyd
Lloyd do you hear hey Lloyd don't worry
sir Lloyd's in the back holding up a
boom box Lloyd Lloyd I'll null and void
in your eyes Lloyd
hi Ralph and Kevin I'm bringing my wife
to the New Year's Eve show all the way
from Calgary oh I'm a foreign country
well as we say here on Hollywood
babble-on
community again that is South Africa
not Carol that's Canada counts for
everything South Canada as well Stampede
country that's true the Stampede country
lot of flames man
my wife is an HBO virgin but she has a
great sense of humor so I think this
will be okay well we'll see Lloyd we'll
see let me set it up for you more like
this this is Carmen Edmonton crowd she's
leaving
we drove all the way from Calgary in a
van with three kids were they yours
loiter just pick them up on the way a
lot of duct tape in the back of the van
line we didn't bring money to get into
the show but here's a 12 year old
from Detroit area this one looks like a
breeder a you can get some good stock
out of these when they grow up
come on they're not ready yet but
someday you took it dark
also brought our 22 year old niece and
her boyfriend they're looking after the
kids tonight
so you think Lloyd's so you think so
wait a second you drove down with them
as well so a van full of seven of you
Sam was seven and two of them are also
adults that you were like [ __ ] you stay
home with our kids welcome to America
well done yeah 22 year old niece and her
boyfriend yeah they're watching the kids
the kids are locked in a trunk and the
niece and the boyfriend or smoking
salvia salvia
salvia I just feel bad cuz he's gonna
happens you know these poor cats
couldn't go home and [ __ ] we're gonna
hear cry in the night dingo ate my baby
once again not Canada Australia oh
you're right my bad the dingo ate our
babies eh
I don't believe there any dingos in the
entire country of Canada fair enough
fair enough
please give my wife a shout it as a
medley of your best Canadian actors I
don't think I do any Canadian actors
why do shatner there you go yeah welcome
to Hollywood babble-on Boyd as I will be
drinking tonight would appreciate any
tips from Ralph on getting back to
Anaheim after the show yeah well first
go to the ATM and get bail and then
drive real fast keep driving till you
see the mouse ears because that's when
you know yeah I know you're trying to be
funny I was trying to be helpful now
you're very helpful
dude seemed lost he's from another
country they drive on this side of the
road though they're that they're okay
he's fine Chris and Colleen Colleen's
here my husband Chris and I are going to
be the New Year's Eve she'll can't wait
to ring in the New Year with you guys
I'm ready list not only because we're
celebrating New Year's Eve but we're
celebrating another occasion as well my
husband of just over a year has quit his
job of 17 years yesterday well you
married him just in time did you mom
he's unemployed now isn't that great you
couldn't be happier people it's amazing
how much a [ __ ] is boss and one
co-worker were that he had to quit but
he has another job lined up but he can't
wait to start he found three Canadian
kids in a trunk he's gonna sell them
that's not right I wrote the shoutouts
let him know that I love him will always
be by his side he is a brave wonderful
man and just for that he will be
acquiring the dirty sheriff's badge
tonight
[Applause]
come on Coleen I was I was having the
David Bowie might be able to sing about
how his old boss and co-workers Albert
and Rob are such as douchebags and wish
him good luck at his job well I'm sure
we could work that out Coleen I really
hate that Albert I really hate that
Rob two douchebags bill new job will be
better after you sell those Canadian
kids you'll be rolling in the mud
[Music]
those two suckers sure will miss you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay like work with Goldie Hawn on
laughing how's that for a reference this
next email is from Tyler and Amy Tyler
and Amy cool all the way on the top guys
Tyler yeah yeah garmi hockey jersey he's
wearing a hockey jersey says Ralph
Garman on it like the kiss army insignia
it was I caught my attention so fast cuz
I was like we should get a piece of that
you'll be hearing from our lawyers
[Music]
girlfriend I've listened to every HBO
since episode one Wow is our first time
coming to the live show all the way from
San Diego we'd love it if you gave a
shout out as David Bowie mostly because
I've always seen - one - Kevin do his
dance but it just happened if you
already make plans to do Bowie in the
show he adds I won't make you do it
again but if that's the case I'd like to
see who perhaps scary clown sorry keV as
a thank you for all the laughs and
possibly a sorry - Kevin for the clown
we built you a special cake that we
could give you after the show well thank
you we will eat it after the show I
promise you I'm gonna make you know what
[ __ ] you I'm gonna do it this year
before I finish this year I'm gonna
[ __ ] face it down you tough it out
yeah right into the now for the clown oh
god you're so [ __ ] like Ralph Gacy
[Laughter]
how about John from Dallas are you here
John right up front man you guys rock
and flew out from Dallas to attend the
Babel Eve show my girlfriend and I
decided to attend the show back in
October before his even announced you
guys are psychic
we got an argument one night and I told
her I was gonna leave for a couple
nights to give her some time to cool
down
well she thought I was leaving for good
so I left and awoke the next morning
only to find she had stolen my email
account Facebook account and deleted
them both I take it she's not with you
this evening John empty chair next to
John okay maybe she was in the bathroom
I was like I can't wait to see her man
then she really [ __ ] up because she
was a Verizon employee and she took my
cell phone off my account and placed it
on her employee account and suspended it
so I had no access to it what did you do
dude she was proud you wanted a little
space and she was like now I want to
destroy your life but John got back at
her I reported this finally got my phone
back and she got fired after working for
Verizon for four years people applauding
unemployment in this economy like
there's a job open I didn't let it get
me down and flew out by myself anyway
right on could Charlton Heston tell her
to keep her damn dirty hands off my
thanks her name is Ellie thanks John
from Dallas well it's the least I could
do John
keep your damn dirty paws off my phone
hey you stinking Verizon employee you
know I found out this week that charlton
heston in Greece is always build as
Charlton Easton I got chills they're
multiplying all of his posters and when
he's built in Greece not that he's in
many movies and if before being dead and
all but whenever he was they would
always build a Miss Charlton Easton
because Heston in Greek apparently means
to be shat on because that his phone the
peril means to [ __ ] on someone I
remember that character did he sing
summer lovin so that's why he changed
his name in Greece you've got the
musical not the movie Grease the country
Kevin I think this is where we're happy
this is where we're having a
communication breakdown I'm making like
Danny Zuko jokes you're not gonna make
Bradley I'm like why won't he pick this
up this
yes well genius might be a little too
far baby was funny
I liked overestimate but in the back of
my head I was gone Tom Heston was in
Greece and as if he was one of the
teachers and I was like oh yeah he was
in the gas station I was like wait that
was Wayne's World conversation I was
having in the back of my head like
Greece in the country of Greece
you know Greece when they say diplomatic
immunity yeah foreign nation the nation
of Greece all right when I hear the
language of Greek yeah estan means to
[ __ ] on someone so instead they're he's
Charlie Eastern that's correct
[ __ ] recently sir I apologize for that
tangent I will do less of that in 2012
next email comes from Dell is Dell in
the house now I'm guessing that's your
beautiful wife Jenna sitting next to you
yes
her breasts almost hit me in the eye
they they were they were bouncing and
they were lovely and I was very
impressed delicate we got to be a neck
up guy man what what are you doing this
job if you can't look at nice tits no I
see Oliver see I look I see of mint it's
somehow you find the one lady in the
room man weird so I roll my wife Jen and
I will be attending all the way from
beautiful Huntington West Virginia oh
nice a lot of pig farms there yeah to
help celebrate my 38th birthday Kevin
might recognize my wife because she
co-starred in Jay and Silent Bob strike
back
Jenna sent a photo of her starring with
you and J in the movie I think we can
throw it up on the screen that is Jenna
behind you guys in Gentile abuzz for
coming out of the theater at the end of
the movie you won the cats passes beyond
its perfect frame right there it is
she bobs in you can see her right there
looking straight down the barrel - she's
looking right in the camera hi mom I
love your work
Dell would like to tell Jenna that I
love her and I'd love to give her a
pearl necklace tonight especially if she
gives up the anal vise garmi strong del
well del you might want to know that
Jenna wrote her own email dearest Kevin
and Ralph my hubby del are longtime fans
of the show you'll probably receive an
email from him tonight telling you that
we will be at the show we're both really
excited to attend the show and del will
probably ask you to convince me to go
anal for him so I thought I would add my
two cents he has a [ __ ] the size of a
Pringles can and though I have loved
anal in the past I have not been able to
bring myself to try it with him with the
exception of one time he tried to switch
lanes without signaling
[Laughter]
a lot of pain Kevin will understand my
reluctance as he shared his anal
fissures story with us in the past Oh
God so the bottom line is he probably
won't be getting the brown eye anytime
soon I just wanted to clarify that it
was not a lack of desire on my part so
happy to be here to ring in the New Year
what's your vote
Thank You Jenna and Dalitz pleasure to
have you I know way more about both of
you than I care to what a human drama
man like you threw her into the jaws of
Jeopardy and [ __ ] and then you rescued
her right at the end you were like it's
cool yeah more importantly delegates a
shout out saying yeah I'm hung like a
Pringles can that's gonna be in the back
of everybody's mind for the rest of the
evening man no matter what happens
matter what we talk about who's famous
and what the [ __ ] someone in this room
has a [ __ ] the size of the Pringles can
and is that flaccid when it's hard yeah
what's it look like flaccid normal
what's normal to you an inner tube if
it's caucus of Pringles can when it's
hard normal is still impressive dinner
with six inches when it's normal hey
Kevin let it go man after the show you
guys can work it out try to wrap my head
around trying to wrap your mouth around
the toga
[Applause]
number one it's not gay on here Z Oh
number two what have you ever seen the
[ __ ] [ __ ] decipher coke every morning
Sun every morning design limp out of the
shower I thought you were all balls I do
have some big balls
how about Nicole's Nicole in the house
you call work where are you Nicole
oh right there hi Nicole flying in from
Colorado for New Year's Eve
to celebrate the fabulousness of Ralph
Garman and Kevin Smith if you find any
let us know which appears we've never
failed to make her laugh during the best
and worst of times of 2011 she says I am
bringing self designed gifts for each of
you to show my appreciation
a small remittance for all the filthy
sex jokes you've given me since I
started listening to HP over a year ago
it's coming up to the stage on dirty
dirty dirty
Piper down what did you what did you
bring us that's something that's Kevin's
it's raps I know thank you so much it's
who may be open and let me open it all
right she's standing right there staring
at us we better open it just watch her
if she starts putting on a gas mask
stop stop opening yeah oh were there
t-shirts this one better be big Ralph I
[ __ ] you not Garmin this is Kevin
you made those yourself well thank you
Nicole how very nice of you
[Applause]
we're gonna work out just fine
it's got a little picture of a dude and
he's got a heart where his diction yep
you know so my friend she knows you
that's awesome thank you I will be alone
because my friend ditched me at the last
minute like a little [ __ ] yeah
oh my call I'm sorry you by yourself I
was wondering if you'd be able to
utilize those pimping skills that keep
people trying to get anal from each
other - give me - excuse me - find me a
nice non-threatening female to kiss at
midnight
Oh Nicole are you are you a lesbianic
you're not you're just a smart kiss a
girl your head reflect level you more
comfortable kissing chicks that makes
you a lesbian buy that cigarette the
definition I think of lesbian if you're
more comfortable kissing women than man
you call girls do you call other girls
sir so you want to kiss a girl or
there's a girl that girl girl is blonde
is like damn you're taking your clothes
off right here already wait for midnight
girl make a love connection right there
I'd love to have a temperament patty in
non-threatening female to kiss at
midnight I'll have an amazing night with
or without a midnight kiss but pretty
much one guarantees the greatest [ __ ]
night of 2011 well in the Cole I don't
know about the [ __ ] night but it were
you kissing night at least and all the
way from Denver well thank you for the
t-shirts and for coming and good luck
with that blonde let me know how it
works out welcome keep my eye right
there you better get kiss fire finally
something took your eye off the Pringles
can I'm glad
to see cigs here your interest leaning
more in a estrogen way it's true he's
he's taken but if she wasn't here I
would say go for that oh man
how big have you visualized a can of
Pringles what I said you could come over
to their place what to the table or a
table I think she means get your [ __ ]
out yeah kevrah moon Ralf Joel Rachel
and Ryan are you guys in the house
tonight
Rachel's like oh they're so embarrassing
my two friends Joel and Rachel drove
with me 1,500 miles from Spokane
Washington tonight thank you so much our
nation's capital when did you roleplay
be the dumb guy of the comedy team
what did you become Tommy smothers all
of a sudden just like watching you stop
Ryan was actually here last New Year's
Eves that true Ryan he wanted to play
the game show we played last year which
was Kevin's closet I think was the game
and he didn't get a chance to and so we
apologize but we will have another game
tonight later on in the show - Ryan till
you have a chance and in fact we should
bring it up now because it's a different
game it's it's the same thing but it's a
little bit different it's called win our
[ __ ] and what Kevin and I have done is
we've emptied out our closets because
during the year we get sent a lot of
promo stuff and a lot of freebies and
things and it accumulates we get [ __ ]
from our kids [ __ ] kids always giving
us [ __ ] and it's all crap Wow oh I'm 20
months older crayon drawing looks like
[ __ ] learn how to [ __ ] draw there's a
[ __ ] card I made in school I like
store-bought so we're gonna give the
stuff away but this year's gonna be a
little different instead of us asking
you trivia questions that you have to
answer we
decided to have you try to stump kevin
and i with your trivia question we want
to do less work this year yes I don't
know if we have a microphone set up or
not for tonight we're gonna need a third
microphone yeah but we thank you James
we've got a wheel here of categories and
what you need to do is come up with a
trivia question for each of these
categories because when you get up here
we're gonna show you what you're playing
for well spin the wheel and wherever it
lands in this case Batman you'd have to
ask us a Batman trivia question if you
stumped us you win whatever is on the
table if you if you don't stumped us
then you [ __ ] right back to your seat I
don't want to hear anything out of you
let's make every category Batman no
let's not I've got some stuff that we
know about though I've got Star Wars on
there and other comic book superheroes
and classic television classic classic
movies and then there's a little little
wedge up here that's win if it lands on
that you just win it and we can't do
anything about it so we'll play that
later on tonight we so think about your
trivia questions for later in the
evening Luke and John are you guys here
Luke and John Johnny just remembered he
was here did you guys bring Matthew and
Mark as well anybody see my old friend
yeah they're gonna be writing about this
for the rest of their lives and Luke and
I are driving from Phoenix Arizona for
the New Year's show right on man
John it's [ __ ] home of Alice early to
rise early to bed a lot of linda lavin
fans in the club tonight and in between
I cooked in clean and
yeah all right that's the theme right
there going to live with blinders on is
tough to see that's the show based on
what movie Alice doesn't live here
anymore it's right mind that was
directed martin scorsees directed the
movie then they made a sitcom called
Alice which he had nothing to do with
and it ran for like nearly a decade yeah
huge live off of a Martin Scorsese but
it's weird
could you imagine they did that like
casino or Goodfellas a sitcom with
Goodfellas would be great Henry guy
borrow some sugar
crazy next-door neighbor hey spider boy
it's not funny good make a sitcom out of
that yes John would watch it John Smith
adds I am NOT brave so I wasn't able to
transport the sacred plant over state
lines I was wondering if Kevin could get
me centered tonight he's hitting you up
for pot yeah woody one of the [ __ ] or
something
centered of a different kind come on keV
my last name is Smith and I have family
in Jersey let's get lit he says yeah no
I'm not your bum not a pusher I'm a
pushy a big fat
[Laughter]
I think you're centered enough for all
of us right now yeah just go breathe my
shirt yeah I've been using Visine all
night and I haven't been look
and lastly Eric and Katie are you guys
in the house Eric and Katie Halloween
aside there oh you can't even they don't
know who's on stage did it's us hi guys
Eric and Katie right we've been fans
since the first episode we even saw one
of the first shows of the old smog
castle holy [ __ ] that's a long time ago
every year the world throws us a party
for our anniversary which happens to be
December the 31st today's your
anniversary happy anniversary
anniversary how long how many years 11
years anniversary this will be gonna be
the show we'd like people to buy us
drinks well I bet you [ __ ] would it's
our anniversary people my wife likes red
wine and I'll have a Jack and Coke we're
not buying you any [ __ ] truth
thanks a lot I hope to have you battle
on for years to come Eric and Katie well
we're not gonna buy you any drinks Eric
and Katie this is somebody will this
dude on the third floor will buy you
drinks well they're in the corner so
come on down to introduce yourself sir
you'll have to come up
well yeah you got to work for it well we
don't want to do something for you Eric
and Katie since it is your anniversary
last year we started a tradition where
we gave out the miss sandwich and mr.
penis awards for an honor of giveth the
penis of sandwich so why don't you guys
come up on stage Eric and Katie come on
up here
[Applause]
[Music]
we've got some
we've got some special things for you to
wear tonight you look all dressed up and
everything you look Katie's got a veil
on and everything here's uh here's the
mr. penis sash for 2012 why don't you
put that on this is a Miss sandwich
right here here is your tiara you wear
this and here's your crown sir you are
this year's official mr. penis and miss
sandwich ladies and gentlemen Eric and
Katie on their on their anniversary
customary to say something at a moment
like this go ahead Andy feel I'd like to
tell you mr. Smith that I am not the
only big fat bastard with a small [ __ ]
who can get a high would you like to say
something about your [ __ ] as well give
it up for Eric and Katie our new mr.
penis in this sandwich 2012
congratulations
couldn't be happier for both of you
that's much cheaper than free drinks
it's like a [ __ ] sash though man yeah
made that myself what else can I do do
you do those little yarn coverings for
the toilet paper cozies paper cozies
yeah sure I can do that for you my
grandmother used to make those creepiest
one's ever she'd take like these dolls
you bought a meadow like a sewing store
and then she'd build them an outfit and
it was a dress that covered the roll of
toilet paper and they had eyes so it was
facing me whenever I went into then I
was a boy so I stand up to pee I would
always look at it it was looking to me
and I would always turn the doll around
you were embarrassed even then faced the
wall it's just like just like literally
just like this it's [ __ ] I was already
like I know it's small and then finally
I couldn't deal with it even at a young
age and stuff then I used to lay her
down so she was looking up and whatnot
yeah Oh lovely actually everyone Ashley
please a round of applause take care of
your waitresses and your waiters they're
working very hard for you tonight
especially actually who's bringing me
free booze so thanks so much you know I
bet my auntie's do the same thing she
made those dial covers yeah and I used
to take take it off the toilet I would
turn it and I would [ __ ] the toilet
paper roll
that never occurred to me yeah closest
thing go woman I had when I was 12 you
know yes so small woman sound I like
them small why as big as my dick yeah I
always felt sorry for the person using
the toilet paper after I finished saying
she could stick together Margaret this
toilet paper is sticky little Ralph was
in there little Ralph needs to stop
[ __ ] this my Uncle Carl was so angry
don't say to him you'll give him a
complex he's gonna give me something
with this I'll tell you I'm with the
show is our next segment one of my
favorites and has been for the majority
of this year it's called [ __ ] that
should not be this is where we take
scenes for movies that are [ __ ] up and
they've gotten passed to everyone who
looked at the movies and somehow got it
through to the film and we've had a
great list of stuff this year some very
very funny stuff and this and please
just for the people who submit all the
time
please stop submitting all of cop-out
yeah that it really hurts to given that
[ __ ] should not be yet the guy did make
it so tonight's suggestion the folks who
were centered in are actually here
Jeremy and aya here Jeremy is it I ever
Asia Asia a band like the heat of the
moment yeah get a get it
telling you what your hot man Kida
moment should in your eyes
[Music]
Jeremie Neiges sent in a scene from Pet
Sematary remember that movie the I don't
wanna be buried yeah the song for that
starring Dale mid Midkiff he played
Elvis once yeah an Elvis in me that this
the story of Priscilla in Elvis I liked
him whatever happened him he was in a
bunch of stuff for a while he was the
star of this film and apparently in this
scene I hadn't seen this a long time
until you guys sent it in for me to take
a look at but he's got a bad nightmare
and he wakes up and this is a case of
not so much [ __ ] that should not be but
just an actor just a [ __ ] trooper
just a guy who just won't say die he's
not gonna be the reason they call cut
I'm gonna tell you that much in this
scene he rolls out of bed and he smashes
his face on the nightstand something
fierce but the best part is Jeremy in
asia-- point out he totally plays it off
look nothing happened nothing wrong to
me oh I think I hurt my shoulder and he
sees these caves in the side of his face
on the corner of the nightstand I
brought in this scene for you to take a
look at because it is something pretty
special it's kind of quick so what I've
done is I put it in rapid succession
afterwards until it becomes like
America's Funniest Home Videos so I hope
you'll enjoy it here's a scene from Pet
Sematary yeah yeah and he's like I'm not
gonna win so I'm not gonna cry out I'm
gonna act I'm just acting on my shoulder
that's where I got it
there's Dale Midkiff now you know why
doesn't work anymore he's got brain
damage apparently where's your [ __ ] that
should not be for this week that was a
good one thank you guys I appreciate you
sending that in this is a dude man that
the Academy should honor yes that's
actor right never mind like I'm Meryl
Streep people like she's amazing yeah
she's amazing I've never seen her
faceplant love that and then [ __ ]
being like Margaret Thatcher yeah didn't
see her take some mahogany to the noggin
in Bridges of Madison County you know
what I said that's acting this is acting
right there ah it's the saddest part of
the night
Kevin this is where I have to say
goodbye to some folks this is the last
addition this year of Tinseltown steps
[Music]
they will indeed be missed
[ __ ] it said Ted's on our point you
drink up and [ __ ] Jam right mate let
me tell you another thing about your
mother
oh why did she leave I'll [ __ ] tell
you why she left
hey Franco make the [ __ ] song go now
[Music]
my inner Sinatra steps listen here you
son of a [ __ ] I know guys who can
[ __ ] kill you and bury you in the
desert next time I say here to kill you
hit it I know all right
Tinseltown sniffs this is a sad one so
let's sober the [ __ ] up people this is
sad Joe bought bottling this is Joe
Paula you may not know his name but you
know his work he was a writer and
Saturday Night Live from 81 to 82
those were the lovitz years no no before
love you was a DS 86 86 more importantly
he was a producer on kids in the hall
and if you are a fan of comedy at all
you know those guys one of the creators
of that show Lorne Michaels put him in
charge of that he killed himself this
week yeah they found him in a Los
Angeles hotel room with a mix of
antifreeze and Gatorade by his side
that's not a good way to go it's not
that's not pain free that's gonna hurt
no it's on the menu too by the way if
you want to check it out tonight it is a
special for too soon way too soon
he wrote on his blog on December the
23rd things I regret my inability to
conquer my alcoholism and that I no
longer able to withstand any more of
life's pain he also I've read the entire
blog when you know this Yorick gruesome
morbid [ __ ] I had to because once
somebody said like this is a suicide
note he's a writer he's a comic this is
a doodoo and he's obviously passionate
artist if you read the piece from top to
bottom this is clearly a man who knew he
was leaving this world forever poured
himself out there and it was just full
of truth and sad truth and wonderful
truth heap there are two things that he
said that really hit me hard he goes of
his regrets one was he said I wish I'd
never left Kanda and I wish I'd never
come to LA and in that moment I was
reading he you forget there's so many
[ __ ] stories of people who are like
imma go out there and [ __ ] you know
do my thing and make my dreams come true
and it happens for a little while and
then eventually it just doesn't happen
for some people this was a dude that it
happened to for a while and then it
started drying up and he was out he were
just getting more and more frustrated
and sadder and and apparently had some
booze problems as well it's really
really sad story but I urge you if
you're anywhere near a computer read
read his blog it's the last thing that
he wrote and there is a lot of truth in
it I bet you know that we can all kind
of pull something from something good
has to come from this you know but don't
don't kill yourself
never never never there could be a phone
call that changed everything
totally and and you know it's like there
are other ways some I feel bad for some
people who came into this business in
one way and the business has changed so
[ __ ] dramatically over the last five
years particularly but slowly over the
last ten and you know there's there's
also ageism in this business where
you've been doing it at a certain point
you're [ __ ] 40 50 60 and [ __ ] they're
like we want young yeah so people get
shuffled out it's it's a cruel business
it's you know it's weird because it's
all about making dreams come true and
[ __ ] but some people really do fall by
the wayside this dude unfortunately it
was one of them I know Nome I don't even
know his work I mean that you know that
year of
now you're talking about I believe that
was the gene domain Ian years wasn't it
yeah I think so maybe I don't know
somewhere in there he also wrote Wayne's
World with my draft but not not the
final read and he was like it wasn't
even close to the one they shot he did a
draft with Mike years before and then
years later they did a whole different
many talks about it in the blog again
like it's see now we're here celebrating
the end of the year sadly this man is
passed but if as ralph says it's
ridiculous to kill yourself I agree you
don't want to criticize somebody in
death but but it is ridiculous don't do
it but honor this dude if you got a
chance and reboot erode comment it's
very sad and it's the as you're reading
it you're going oh my god clearly this
dude's wrapping up because he's just
like here's this here's this here's this
kind of puts it all out there touching
he said apparently his biggest fear was
he'd end up doing a podcast he wanted to
end it all before it came to bed yes
before it comes the podcast thing I want
to check out it didn't say I was afraid
I'd do a podcast that's my job that'd be
really hard to take also this week you
lost cheetah Tarzan's chimpanzee
companion cheetah died that's a bummer
but you know come on
cheetah yeah whatever I know who cheetah
was I didn't know who Joe Penna
pentathlon Ayano was I know but cheetah
didn't write a lot of really thanking
blog cheetah was just if you had gone
near cheetah cheetah would have eaten
your [ __ ] face that is not true these
things I these things at the moment they
hit puberty to God trainers told me the
like you can work with them they'll ride
bikes smoked cigarettes put on outfits
and [ __ ] like that
they hit puberty they [ __ ] throat a
bike down put the cigarette out in your
I know your face on it one not nice
Cheeta Cheeta was different he was a
different breed of monkey you think so
and he was 80 years old what he passed
away he wasn't eating anybody's face up
he was may be gumming your face off he
was 80 years old
you might have looked like you saw the
Rise of the Planet of the Apes right
yeah he might look like the one that was
in the lab and then spoilers he [ __ ]
he's on the bridge and he's like okay I
don't want cover years we haven't seen
he kills the one [ __ ] what but he
looked all of this [ __ ] man like
really old and [ __ ] you're like was this
old-timer gonna do but at the end of the
movie Ralph he winds up doing something
but is weird Hollywood's full of
original ideas what it is this guy
worked with John Donne this guy of
course he's a monkey this monkey worked
with Johnny Weissmuller the original
Tarzan back in the 30s that's right he
has he had talents he lived them I lived
everybody finger-painting watching
football and was soothed by Christian
music
it says here well who isn't who does
like a good him I prefer her here's the
scene starring cheetah from a movie
where a cheetah finds a Nazi radio in
the jungle you're laughing but cheetah
you may not know this did an excellent
impression of Adolf Hitler and in this
scene he actually fools the Nazis into
thinking he's Hitler [ __ ] happy years is
right
please watch
[Music]
[Music]
jeez what a wacky bunch with detours and
meet the Nazis man
it was the 30s everybody fought the
knobs like I love Johnny White's Miller
to those a good old days in the 30s I
could have been an action star in the
30s
Johnny why suppose there with his man
tits in his loincloth just standing
there the jungle yeah me Tarzan you Jane
anybody look at that body when he was
soft that Tarzan [ __ ] did Tarzan meet
Nazis like what could he do
dude the Nazis were you get out of
jungle put him in the shower oh wow too
soon man you're absolutely right I feel
bad here's the second what we like to
call well we don't like to call it it's
what it's called it's called exquisite
acting we're great actors maybe have an
off day welcome to the world of
exquisite acting we talked about this
movie last week we're talking about Nick
Nolte and we talked about his work in
the Incredible Hulk remember that mm-hmm
we thought it was appropriate listener M
Tilden sent in this scene there's a this
whole movie is just horrible but this
seems in particular there was so much to
choose from I had to pick one little
moment and it's a twofer really cuz you
got Eric Bana acting his ass off and you
get Nick Nolte way over acting and the
two of them are screaming and yelling
and stuff but there's one moment where
Nick Nolte does this little bit which i
think is hilarious I wanted to bring it
in for this is Nick Nolte over the top
with his exquisite acting
and be reborn but hero and they
calendars long before the religious
civilization in fact it looks more like
David Lynch's Eraserhead man it's just
so disjointed that's all [ __ ] up let's
take a look at the HBO headlines shall
we
[Music]
isn't this something after they
bludgeoned us with their relationship
and how much they were just more in love
than anyone had ever been Russell Brand
and Katy Perry are getting divorced a
lot of people are ugly she's she's
single she's hot we all got a chance
this is this is my least favorite look I
don't wish anyone divorce yes but they
kept saying all these rumors about us
speaking of trouble it's a ridiculous
and it's the lying media and the
tabloids are awful and they keep saying
we're in trouble where were so much in
love and everything's wonderful
and they kept tonight $2.99 and now
today or yesterday they announced that
they're filing for divorce
here's that he was the give away
Christmas they were not together
Christmas it sounded like I mean I read
a piece online who knows [ __ ] how
much these people know but somebody said
that she wanted to spend Christmas I
mean the tipping point when she wants to
spend Christmas in Hawaii with a bunch
of friends they were supposed to go to
London and be with his family
she chose friends and then the next day
in London he went out without the ring
and then [ __ ] she wasn't wearing her
ring in Hawaii there really yeah he
issued a statement what I read is he
issued a statement of sadly we're
getting divorced it's a bummer and he
hadn't told her or her people and they
were like what the [ __ ] now I heard she
asked him to file because her parents
are super religious and really against
divorce and she didn't want to look bad
in her parents eyes right he divorces
her it's less of a sting for the family
really well maybe how long are they were
they married total because maybe she
might be able to get it an old they got
married in I think October of last year
okay so if they didn't have sex they're
fine yeah knowing Russell Brand I think
very good shape I'm sure they're pretty
chaste but Kate Perea was in Christmas
wasn't Hawaii for Christmas and she was
not wearing a ring I looked at this
picture I looked at it very closely and
I did not find a ring anywhere that's
beauty pear yeah
sir she has hands the gentleman asked
[Applause]
Russell said Katie and I are ending our
marriage
I'll always adore her and I know we'll
remain friends of course you will
because divorced couples are always the
best of friends just ask anyone
they gotta be I feel a little bad I
remember we talked about yeah I think
I'm Hollywood babble-on
when he was like first date her and
whatnot and he was like I want to go see
you while I'm in town he was very very
very very very much in love this is what
I'm talking about two weeks ago he was
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show yes and she
asked about the rumors that there was
trouble in the relationship and it's
like it's wrong we love each other
here's the video you want to see this is
his and see how close my impression was
okay here we go
looks just like us yes that means he's
gonna die soon no Arthur - we're safe I
like him he's a good guy man and he's
you know he's due to his kind of cleaned
up his life you had substance abuse
problems yeah but I like him he's funny
he's pretty he's pretty straightforward
dude very real I mean I know he caught
him obviously [ __ ] trying to cover up
something that was crumbling but what do
you say when you don't say well till
death do us part and I'm not dead so
we're not good we're gonna stay maybe
it's another way maybe the Christmas Day
thing pushed him over the top or push
him over the edge we was just like did
you see her in that bikini I would have
found a way to get over whatever the
problem was that would have solved it
for me just that this is what a
motorboat motorboated her right back in
the happiness that's what I was
while we're talking about relationships
good news ladies Mel Gibson is
officially back on the market he is
single the judge signed off on the
paperwork allowing him to divorce his
wife of 28 years Robyn they are
officially split up wait you have a shot
with Robyn yes you do and you want one
because there's no prenup milk wait wait
Mel Gibson after all thank you sir after
all this time they've been separated
they'd filed the papers but now it's
official
and but isn't he also like getting sued
or working on settling up with the other
chick it wasn't oksana grigory yeah yeah
I'm still working on her too but this is
the white that was just the girlfriend
this guy's been a lot of [ __ ] play
yeah no no prenup which means they're
gonna split his net worth which is
estimated to be 900 million dollars so
she's gonna say you get 450 mil even
when you have 900 mil that hurts
losing 450 no I good for her you know
what's gonna happen man you go in the
office lawyer's office sign that [ __ ]
paper stand up look at him at the desk
be like diplomatic immunity and then
drop a car on him or something Mel said
he's happy that the whole thing is
behind him and he thanked the Jew lawyer
who got it for him that was a joke he
didn't really say that don't sue Mel
Sinead O'Connor also got divorced if I
follow the news he is not a fan of Jews
you probably did say something to that
effect wrap up here well seriously boy
why wait now listen to me I'm trying to
give him facts sinead o'connor's
divorced oh that hurts after 18 days of
marriage she got divorced that's like
that's like a sixth of a Kardashian
that's how they measured them no I think
18 days later she broke up with her
husband Barry header Harry head ridge
builders they got married in Las Vegas
Nevada what a lovely place to get
married they did it at a drive-through
wedding chapel mm-hmm in the back of a
pink Cadillac here's a photo of them
driving through getting married on their
wedding day
oh isn't she lovely when you do one of
those when you do a drive-through
wedding
once you pull up and you're in the car
and they do it as if you're [ __ ] like
at a drive-through yes
once you're wet if you pull up five feet
can you [ __ ] right there in the car
absolutely
can you consummate her with a belt about
a state law you can [ __ ] in a car as
long as you've been married I would like
to just hang on brother all day and
watch people four and then wish him well
on their marriage
honey go through a drive-through wedding
jab don't serve that here content so
hard be careful what are you talking all
that what are you - hold on this is
about marriage not food okay
that's better or shamrock change
I have sneaked that in for the drinking
game as I know you just want to hit that
drink again
eighteen days later teen days of married
divorced I can see why the heterosexuals
want to hold on to marriage is something
sacred we do do it right don't we yeah
yeah well you can't get married but we
can brave teen days she said he's a
wonderful man
I love him very much I'm sorry I'm not
more regular woman he has been terribly
unhappy and I have therefore ended the
marriage I think he is too nice to do so
and too nice to trap 18 days well here's
the thing after they got married white
after they get married she doesn't drink
so she demanded that they go look for
drugs says year she took Barry to a
shady part of town looking for marijuana
he wasn't happy about this at all mainly
because he is a drug counselor sinead
could not find marijuana so she settled
for a bag of crack haven't we all at
some point in the evening settled for a
bag of crack Barry was not only angry he
was also very scared and apparently that
was the beginning of the end
he's like we've only been marriage it's
been seven hours and 15 days
nothing compares to you Sinead Junaid
told everything I love this story and
others to the press when they showed up
at her house looking for an answer
she did her interview in front of her
house wrapped in a towel here's a shot
of her hanging out of her door talking
to journalists I love that she stills
Halloween decorations hanging over her
door she is a catch
Barry Barry you dodged a bullet son you
dodged a bullet was that remember when
we talked about her on the show where
she was like I just want to get poked
like she's desperate frame it was that
what it was a bad guess she found Barry
and but she wanted to get to [ __ ] and
stoned and he's the drug count he's like
I can only do one of those that's right
you and her have a lot in common but
that's weird what how weird to be like I
can't find weed so I'll smoke crack
instead same thing my favorite show up
is three the week turns out to be fake
it bums me out and if you saw this
leaked cover from People magazine or not
this one came out with Taylor Lautner on
the cover yeah Taylor Lautner out bro
HRM gay not if I find you purge these
two when you do him and you do the two
hands like this does he have two dicks
this hands apparently not apparently
that was a fake cover but it was a great
great hoax that was played on the
internet everyone bought it including
Russell Simmons who tweeted the day it
was released on the internet that he was
proud of Taylor Lautner for his bravery
and his courage the cover red tired of
rumors the Twilight star opens up about
his decision to finally come out I'm
more liberated I'm sorry I'm more
liberated and happy than I've ever been
he said but sadly it was fake you first
when I Drive a motorcycle and there's
gonna be heck to pay let's do the final
scene from that movie from abduction
yeah I'm the Eurotrash villain guy okay
you're going to leave this planet
screaming oh I'm so sore at you right
now how sore I really look I got a I got
a weapon here somewhere hold on a second
I'm not go get a weapon when I come back
you're in big trouble fella do you even
have her driver's license I got a permit
that's good enough
diplomatic immunity extra Michael
Jackson's mom made news this week
apparently she was vacationing the
holidays in Las Vegas Nevada a lot of
people do okay I did Christmas in Vegas
once and I took the whole family mom and
dad and my wife and my sister we all
went to Vegas just to shake things up
get away from the same old same old to
do Christmas in Vegas sad it's
depressing it's your Christmas in Vegas
why how many people a lot of people a
lot of people there but a lot of a lot
of sad people there a lot of people with
no place else to go
really I don't like that's my god
Richard Gere was there and Lou Gossett
jr. was giving him a hard time
want you to leave this cuz you don't
blow mayonnaise no don't call the devil
where came in victim I walked out so
Katherine Jackson was in Vegas and she
made some news because of her odd choice
some people thought this was odd here's
the photo she took and sent to friends
it's her at the Imperial Palace with a
Michael Jackson impersonator looks just
like your dead son but I mean I don't
know he's true he's gone from her son to
like [ __ ] icon like he's a almost a
fictional character at this point it's
almost like standing next to Mickey
Mouse Mickey Mouse didn't come out of
her vagina that would be a little weird
I guess but like my mother has to stand
next to fat bearded people all the time
I'm sure she's always like oh my son my
Dolly Parton's in the news believe it or
not you know they're the big thing now
on Broadway is to take the the entire
catalogues of famous musicians and build
Broadway shows around yes with Abba Abba
and the Jersey Boys and other people
anyway they're doing one for her
developing a Broadway musical based on
her life story now often Dolly's thought
of just 9 to 5 and a couple hits that
she had but she's a serious musician she
has written over 5,000 songs for herself
and for other artists yes like The
Bodyguard song Whitney Houston that a
big hit with
[Music]
let's and easy tonight yeah 5,000 songs
and they're gonna portray that part of
her career so because of that the name
of the show apparently is going to be
Wow look at those tits
[Laughter]
[Music]
we'll always he's always in the news
that's why she's got a song lindsay has
finally got a job that requires her to
keep her clothes on
[Music]
did you see the Playboy it's not so bad
for anybody really we win she wins it's
a win-win
you saw playboy yeah yeah it's fine it's
supposed to be a throwback to Marilyn
Monroe's photo shoots was very stark and
very sort of flat it's not very
flattering for her really good she is
signed up with a country called company
called jag jeans jag jeans has announced
that she will be their newest celebrity
spokesperson who are they [ __ ]
kidding they're only celebrity
spokesperson they said in their press
release Lindsey embodies the strength
and fearlessness of the woman of today
this is the ad campaign gonna be her
like get your jag off mopping up the
morgue when I clean up embalming fluid
my ass looks great in jag jeans Lindsey
is fierce yet exudes feminine grace they
add the line of jeans will be called
airtight apparently very very tight
jeans Kim card at me pornstar Kim
Kardashian in the news
I think by the way you know we have
people have been sending in potential
theme songs for Kim Kardashian she's in
the news every week I think we finally
have a winner because they used you in
the jingle that's always a good sign
that's they appeal to our ego here's the
new theme I think it works
[Music]
all right from Justin slaughter is his
name Justin slaughter I liked his name
Justin slaughter yeah totally murderer
he's an or GI Joe figure I heard he was
killed by destro Kim Kardashian in the
news this week because she was tweeting
Barbie on Christmas and it made people
think she lost her [ __ ] mind never
was following her Twitter account and
she said Merry Christmas barbs to Barbie
style long time no see what did Ken get
you for Christmas miss you doll Barbie
wrote back which is even weirder happy
Holidays to you Kim Kardashian see you
in 2012 which Kim added I'm sure we'll
be seeing lots of each other
shopping soon XO Kim then it dawned on
people yeah Kim Kardashian is a
money-grubbing [ __ ] and the speculation
is now that Mattel is going to release a
collector's edition Kim Kardashian
Barbie doll and this is all this is all
a big ploy to increase sales all right
how much time do we have left before the
new year it is 11:28 about a half an
hour to go yeah which is perfect we
could play our our game show how about K
let's do it ma'am once again here's the
here's the game if you want to win some
of our [ __ ] and we'll be pulling stuff
out periodically and throwing up in the
table to see what you play for you need
to come up with a trivia question for us
in one of these categories now prepare
yourself because the wheel could land
anywhere so have a trivia question ready
at the hand we're gonna bring it up to
the microphone we got one now and you
will ask us your trivia question if you
can stumped us you win whatever we bring
up on the table it's just that simple
it's called win our [ __ ]
it's time for America's favorite new
game show where you ask the questions
it's [ __ ] and here are your hosts Ralph
Garman and Kevin Smith hi I'm kind of
interested in winning your [ __ ] well
Kevin I cleaned out our closets we got
some interesting [ __ ] hey that guy like
your mom man there's like don't give
that away
every time you try to give a prize away
tonight if anybody would like to play
the game just come on over here to where
the stairs are we're gonna have you come
up on the stage holy [ __ ]
so riot come on up and we're gonna spin
the wheel let's see what you're gonna
play for first let's play with a big one
first the Hal Jordan just beautiful
ladies and gentlemen this is a sweet
prize Warner Brothers gave out these
cool kind of viral packages in advance
of the opening of that cinematic giant
the Green Lantern yeah the movie sucked
but the merch was great merch was very
cool and this package was very very neat
they sent it out months in advance in
the movie tell them what it is it's like
Hal Jordans Locker from Ferris aircraft
and inside is a hat and a sweatshirt and
a t-shirt and the Green Lantern ring but
the coolest thing is when you open it
this happens
I don't know where that sound comes from
but it says the Green Lantern knows when
you open it up it does it says Ryan
Reynolds creepily going in brightest day
in blackest night it is the most
unsettling thing since Ralph doing the
clown
when you hear it it's you'll be I don't
know if you'll be too happy to win it
what's going on look could you produce
in the show and [ __ ] oh you want a
lampshade on your head right on man
happy new year what's your name there
sir
what is it right into the microphone
Paul bill Annette right on man where'd
you get that party see where else do you
get a lampshade hey Marcus easy dude all
right sir we're playing for a Ferris
aircraft Hal Jordan footlocker well
you're a comic book guy at all I am okay
great we're gonna spin the wheel and if
it lands on a win you just win it
anything else you have to ask us a
trivia question right gotcha
give us pink heaven the category is
classic movies you have to ask us a
trivia question about classic movies no
props on that's been it was an awesome
spin Kevin it wasn't a couple times it
was awesome don't get me wrong I'm sorry
I didn't give you enough praise for your
[ __ ] spin of a wheel it felt strong
all right now keep in mind people what
difference we trivia minutiae - okay by
the way you know we're not we're not
super geniuses we just know some [ __ ] so
let's give us a go Paul what do you got
for us okay
who are the two lead actors for the
Buddha's sakes movie Boondock Saints
movie classic film lead actors I'm gonna
say one was the kid from powder and the
other Sean Patrick Flanery don't help us
and that's fine to win something the
other was a kid from the walk in bed and
he Bobby zombie
hold on what's it say hold on oh [ __ ] he
was in that movie that he just mentioned
Boondock Saints oh yeah five seconds
Bob sighs wait does it have to be those
as any two stars like willing to follow
the main to a classic all right we
didn't know the rules so give us an
extra 15 seconds all right we'll take
ten go on the Internet no Paul wins what
was the answer follows the answer then
you don't know
let's give it to them let's get it to
him Oh No congratulations you I don't
think that was a real win but Ralph's
nice we didn't clarify before we started
the game what is his name do you want to
eat to know the answer
hold on what's that your wire Norman
Reedus
that Ria's Paul you're lucky we're
generous and I don't want to have that
[ __ ] footlocker in my closet any
longer sir what's your name
my name is Marshall Marshall let's see
what Marshalls playing for shall we have
a routine expedition
oh come on something awesome something
awesome oh I want this this is the Criss
Angel Mindfreak magic kid angry over 250
Mindfreak magic tricks holy [ __ ] Ralph
it's got a DVD inside that teaches you
how to levitate oh my god that's what
you're playing for sir give it a spin
keV there we go
all right I'm ready I'm ready thanks man
classic television is your category
classic it's the one thing that I didn't
have a pre-written down quick I told you
to prepare I had four other questions
ready classics movies movies okay okay
what what classic Humphrey Bogart movie
good one good is the Coen brothers big
lebowski based upon
I think you're right I think you're
right is it Treasure of the Sierra Madre
no what is it it is the Big Sleep
The Big Sleep of course Yeah right on
man you won Congrats sir Congrats thanks
for making me feel stupid
alright what else we got [ __ ] how about
the yeah come on up rock the mic come on
up
hi there turn that microphone down so
you can get your mouth around it
well you know do whatever it is you want
to do them what's your name
Casey I can't see you are playing for a
Batman Arkham City bat-arang controller
for the the video games
pretty cool huh which system is it do
you know I don't know what's Xbox it's
for Xbox so it all works out this is
meant to be Casey this is yours - oh my
god well you think you're that woman on
the back have you played this game no
but I this is scandalous yeah you could
see her heinie crack you could see the
brown eye Catwoman's brown eyes
Catwoman's brown eye let's all go away
inside all right Casey this is yours
no it's got a t-shirt into it does
t-shirts and a ps3 controller not oh I'm
sorry not yesterday yeah but you know
maybe you could sell it to somebody and
get an Xbox controller for it we're
gonna spin and see what your category is
all right oh I'm sorry Kevin go ahead no
it's you man yours almost like an OSHA
work-related accident right there
Kevin lost a finger that night what do
we got
amazing spin yeah thank you classic
movies that's all we've had is classic
movies can you name all five Planet of
the Apes movies oh sorry feel free we're
out of the apes beneath the Planet of
the Apes escape from the Planet of the
Apes let me know if you need any help
conquest of the Planet of the Apes
battle for the Planet of the Apes oh
well done Casey I'm sorry but you leave
empty-handed
I've no way to maybe you don't know you
don't you know what I got a shitload of
Green Lantern rings it lights up and
everyone
looks like a party again I got a ton of
these for you Casey
sorry I [ __ ] your game up no I'm
strong
that's right who's next who's next Jenna
wearing a garment I like that sir what's
your name Michael Trujillo Michael no
let's see what Michaels got a playboy I
should we keep the arkham city
controller gonna play for that yes three
or no you want something new
hey man reach into that bag that white
t-shirt oh yeah okay this is a t-shirt
zack and miri t-shirt star [ __ ] you're
in luck because quite like you I'm a
large man v XL you can invite people
into the shirt with you sell star [ __ ]
t-shirt it could be yours if you can ask
us a trivia question that stumps us
based on the following category
I'm superheroes yeah finally we'll be
waiting for it do you have a severe
questioner do you have another question
for all categories I'm good man you were
there so when in the Batman TV show the
classic one oh when he meets the Green
Hornet what was the object that they
were trying to counterfeit what was the
villains object they're trying to
counterfeit oh I see when you were
talking about the two episodes they met
the Green Hornet you see piece of the
added piece of the action Batman
satisfaction with the name of the two
episodes no Kevin Kevin no weird tour a
team man yeah I'm not good this is his
forte his territories animus Batman show
I have a general guest but are you
looking for specific what would the
counterfeiting in that in that in that
to two parties get stamps yeah oh sorry
Michael better luck next time
hey kid hey kid like Mean Joe green can
pull that microphone up a little bit sir
so we can hear you and tell us your name
Ryan welcome Ryan again welcome sir
we're gonna spin the wheel don't know
what he's playing for yet that in the
Arkham City it is Batman whoo which
actor was considered for Joker and the
Riddler movies me or you want me to go I
got this in the bag
get your [ __ ] ahem Robin Williams Robin
wins yes sorry sir hey you want a Green
Lantern ring here you go it's a Green
Lantern ring for you come on up who's
next who wants to win our [ __ ] it's 20
minutes left to 2011 20 minutes on 20
minutes until the brand-new year
[Applause]
what's your name there sire Tris
Breedlove
what a great you better cure cancer with
a name like that
I'm trying or I got a porn star or at
least AIDS
that's not your crown by the way that's
mr. penises crown Breedlove no he gave
it to me oh sure he did I bought him
we're gonna find his body in a shallow
grave someplace certainly who offered
free drinks I bought them
oh good also in exchange the end of the
crown he gave me the crown entire
kingdom for boon exactly that's my kind
of man
i abdicate the throne for a drink
welcome sir you want to play for the
Arkham City controller or yes sir
yeah the ps3 no this is of no use to you
then not at all not at all you're a
strange man crisp but we're gonna hide
you play yeah we know video games he
just wins it he hit the wind I got the
wind you can have that what you can't
use or give you a Family Guy Stewie pint
glass there you go Chris nice to meet
you
well he won he just wanted it's just
that easy folks to win here and win our
[ __ ] I just want to give him props that
was the firmest strongest handshake I've
received all year long my hand hurts
he's Chris Breedlove hey man welcome
thank you what's your name my name is
David David you know one tells you last
name because you're afraid people at
work are gonna hear care my name is
David King
how'd you real last name where's that
the Navy gift chicks when you're in bar
like what's your name like David David
King see what his category is
superheroes superheroes David Keene now
keep in mind you can play for the Stewie
family guide pint glass which says party
naked or the Arkham City controller if
you have a ps3 I do have a ps3 and like
to go for the controller on man I like
it Zuko here a controller superheroes is
your category you gotta stump me and
Kevon okay this is a bad name related
once
a lot of Batman yeah okay so in in
Batman Beyond universe who came back as
the Joker Batman beyond the universe
yeah in that in the world's universe who
came back as the Joker Oh Batman I got
this
Jason table wrong who was it it was Tim
Drake stick grace Drake
Tim Drake my potemkin son I know hey
we're a team how about a little
conference here welcome
put a little conferring he had a
Playstation you had to win man
a good time for a couple more before man
I am Gabe wait a minute did you have a
posse yes
I've seen those stickers all around town
Dave as a possum I have no idea there
were them as a side note I'm the guy
that made the other the six days seven
nights one butthole poster poster
position I have to say that without
exaggeration it was one of the greatest
moments of my life
if you haven't laughed at it it's
probably you've it you would make me
laugh so much inside in 15 years old
hearing you laugh one of my jokes here
leather jacket what do you think looks
pretty cool he gets really sensitive
including big time oh yeah how was my
spin come on
I think you've been doing a great job
spinning around
what what I don't like I don't like this
guy I want him out of here
that was severe it was it was awesome
all right now how about a how about a
set of Batman Christmas lights
[ __ ] yeah my girlfriend will love them I
want this all right how about great
minds right Kevin
how about what size are your t-shirts I
am an extra-large this isn't gonna help
you at all here man do you like trading
cards Captain America movie trading
cards [ __ ] it yeah I'll take okay no
good this lump in I'll take it good
let's see what category he's playing for
cab give a spin here we go
was that whoa for my spin you rock
Batman Oh Batman
no [ __ ] let's confirm I'll put this up
with this out there you can win the
Batman lights and the Captain America
cards if you could come up with a
question about Batman Batman okay so in
Batman legends of The Dark Knight
whoo gothic where does Batman travel to
find out about the dead priest guy do
you or do you have a shot at this or no
now that's sad I'm sorry long time ago
just read it it was for 99 cents I'd
read it it was like Neil Gaiman Rhoda
right I want to save France man but just
because you said London I want to say
France and then I want to see that I saw
your underpants now what are we gonna do
I know we're [ __ ] after that I'm gonna
go with the Vatican clothes it was the
this the sunken monastery of deaths in
Bavaria that's not even close too close
[ __ ] one
one the light got his job you stumped
that that was a tough one good question
man oh hey she comes up here all the
time ladies gentlemen give it up for
Gabby Gabby she runs the joint in one
time that's right okay man who loves you
want a ring
agree on that you're gonna ask a
question get up to the mic cuz I don't
know anything on that wheel justjust
take the ring and go you're just the
dude that's just like this categories
for a thousand they're like this is too
hard Alex you're like just take it on
take it look at this this is a good one
this is sweet
this is sweet this is a good year ender
right here this is Trivial Pursuit the
millennium this is the whole [ __ ]
whole [ __ ] century right here right
there man as a fun gift that's what
you're playing for what's your name
what's your name sir now is this up your
alley or your like I hate trivia I want
everything I want to have a gun on you
know okay all right let's throw one more
thing I think it's great yeah
you look like you want to win it you
want to play against I just don't know
how excited he is it's a great gift I'm
always excited you're oh I can tell
you're a bundle of energy right now Pete
Star Wars Star Wars at the Chronicles I
was
I needed help too easy too who is the
actor that played Boba Fett Jeremy Bowen
okay
sorry sir [ __ ] with the wrong guy what
do you want I matter rings hey wait hold
on give them a box of cards yeah how
about a complete set of Thor movie
trading cards there you go know the good
folks good folks upper deck want you to
have that loved Thor that's good news
come on up man have one more question
that I think we should bring up our
special guests shall we yeah we show a
girl or I can give you Stewie ice cube
tray I can give you a Stewie ice
I'd rather Trivial Pursuit I will tell
Seth MacFarlane you hate him fine no
problem should we ask menacing the
categories playing for
[Laughter]
are you Batman familiar we warned you
yeah in the movie Catwoman you have
spoken the word that shall not be names
in the movie Catwoman there is no Batman
in the movie Catwoman what is the name
of Halle Berry's character ooh what's
Catwoman secret identity Kevin in
Catwoman it wasn't no it was different
slappy tickle was it [ __ ] Yvonne movies
I do not remind that's a good one but
you better know it do you know it was
patience congratulations you've won
yourself a Trivial Pursuit millennium
edition if you let Kevin hang and just
like that shake the man's hand be no
living with him if you don't shake his
hand trust me it's true after the show
the back thank you okay no shoutouts get
off the stage mom and dad thanks for
everything you've ever done for me
my boyfriend I'm a sucky tonight I love
you all good night
should we bring some special people up
at the end of the year and give them
special thanks let's do it man but I
mean it's we got a lot of time you want
to do another question I think we should
let's do like two more questions anyone
else want Winston [ __ ] we got three
people left all right here we go up to
the mic all right what do we got what do
we got what do we get we got what's your
name sir hey about this any Bell does
ready are you a Marvel Comics fan at all
more of a DC fan see what we can do for
it there might be no no I got marble
left are your family got fan at all yeah
alright do a twofer I'll do the Stewie
ice cube tray and the Stewie pint glass
this is good I'll do you two talk about
the ShamWow the chairman's to make great
stuff okay okay can you sweeten that pot
I don't got American Pickers [ __ ] it's
just the game chugs better to make a
deal here let's see what you playin
right in in Arkham City the video game
who's the surprise end boss in the very
end of the game spoilers sorry spoilers
spoilers wow I have not played I don't
know lady
[ __ ] me take a guess though yeah totally
alright [ __ ] you alright we're gonna say
mr. freeze who wasn't was it
Clayface Clayface alright man you one
brother that's slimy bastard there you
go there's your twofer right there sir
god damn it this guy said alright come
on up sir Oh sir pick it up here hey
someone's angel from Dexter is here to
see
[Applause]
let me tell you something Dexter what's
your name sergeant Batista Johnny D sir
excuse me Johnny D Johnny D welcome
Johnny this man he'll see what size so a
size t-shirt are you um I can fit into a
large okay I got it a large American Dad
t-shirt if you're interested sorry but
and see what else we got are you a
marvel fan at all pretty good yeah
hockey fan what God not a hockey fan not
a hot iron ooh
the category is going to be classic TV
classic
can I do maybe stole a Batman yes now
who's playing fast and loose with the
rules well is it cop it's true he is
with Miami PD not a good one though we
can never figure out Dexter the killers
hey Kevin if I win can I get a hug from
you yeah [ __ ] you okay
we were gonna give you prizes but if you
just want a hug that's Star Wars here's
your question Star Wars okay which Star
Wars film did not gross three hundred
million dollars domestically the
Christmas special I'm guessing the
Christmas custom no Empire Strikes Back
[Music]
[Applause]
aha give them a hug
this part again welcome good sir you're
the last contestant for the evening
alright alright if you win you win you
win
The Avengers you win the complete black
books ghouls Dylan Moran oh this is
pretty banner please go over alright you
go last you know just give it to her
she's got giant cans I'm gonna
whitewater the gym at Heart Walk that I
got why does she get a car
her husband has a caucus site of a
Pringles can welcome you labrum or Eva B
she's from West Virginia isn't that bad
enough she's been through so much Kevin
welcome all right you get the Avengers
to get the ax the muscle [ __ ] guy he's
gonna benefit from it he already has a
giant [ __ ] like the rich get richer man
and the American Dad t-shirt you get
everything we have left everything we
have left sir here we go
classic flicks classic flicks terms
wavin horrors did I see clicks I said
Batman sorry my bad now I know how to
make the wheel next year little
background which Robin was the only
Robin to be called Detective biracial I
know this one I know this one
do you yes really yes are you gonna I'm
gonna let you go if you're gonna go I
know it go it's kind of a trick question
because he was called detective while he
was Red Robin but it's Tim drink yes it
was take the [ __ ] away anyway just take
it away let's go because I read [ __ ]
comic books Wow thank you for helping us
empty out our closet Canada hat oh well
there's always next year
well we don't have that anymore well
done ladies and gentlemen this is an
awesome show that me and this guy enjoy
doing the [ __ ] out of every weekend's
here we've been doing it for now over
over a year at this point and it's bliss
coming to do to here to do the show with
Ralph is fantastic I thank you from the
bottom of my heart for letting us do it
give yourselves a big round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
and every week if you guys aren't here
you're downloading the show from iTunes
or you're going to SModcast calm and you
and the numbers keep getting bigger and
bigger and we have you to thank for that
and we really do thank each and every
one of you for all your support for this
year and do your previous as well you
guys are fantastic
honestly you fuel the show and we can't
thank you enough man it makes us happy
it's the thing that we enjoy a lot we
love coming here seen you all week after
week but there there are two people that
we got to bring up and thanked because
they give us up every Saturday night
yeah bring up quick yeah bring them up
real [ __ ] fast
ladies and gentlemen our significant
others yes
our wives my wife Carrie I won't have it
come up allowing me to come play with my
friend in the sandbox every Saturday
night ladies and gentlemen the woman I
put my wiener in Jennifer's wah-bah also
our good friend Jason Mewes in the house
is Jason anywhere he's not here he had
to go home he's not here
he was Santa's love but he keep an eye
on the time the data behind his calves
you renowned afford out of seconds
artificial New Year's resolutions Ralph
just try to be a better friend a better
father a better husband I'm gonna try to
get laid more and lose a little weight
all right fair enough
28 seconds ladies and gentlemen thanks
for being here again thanks for making
this the second a New Year's Eve er we
actually get to go out kinda and and and
be here next year when we'll do it again
absolutely
here we go man it's countdown time 10 9
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 happy
Happy New Year everybody from all the
see Hollywood babble-on all you he
remember one listen at home have a great
to 2012 and we'll be back with you in
the new year for Hollywood babble-on
and that hot blonde kissed Nicole the
girl who wanted to kiss at midnight what
I'm talking about
wait a second zip anybody shoot that do
shoot that you got it well done a new
stir with the Pringles can [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] out on that table right now no
don't don't do it really that was
exciting for Hollywood battle on this
year I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
this is and this is Carey Garmin happy
here each and every one of you babble
the [ __ ] on ladies gentlemen good night
and goodbye 2011
party we don't have to go home yet let's
all treat and get [ __ ] up what do you
say
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you